with the war in ukraine now beyond the
100-day mark some western capitals are
pressing harder for peace talks to bring
the fighting to an end in europe unity
over ukraine has passed its peak with
divergence in the eu over the continued
supply of weapons to ukraine
so what will it take to bring the
fighting to an end what other pathways
to peace i discussed this with one of
germany's most seasoned diplomats
wolfgang ishinger
ambassador ishingay it's uh good to see
you and a great pleasure to be talking
to you at this time
what do you make of russia's recent
gains in the donbass is is russia likely
to achieve its new stated objective
of taking the entire donbass region
well first of all
let's be clear
that russia's original
war aims
have of course not been reached
uh the original idea was obviously from
all we know from president putin's own
statements and and other statements
uh was
to uh
to conquer ukraine to get rid of of
ukraine as a as an independent uh
country so
that obviously has not been achieved uh
the limited
um
forward movement which russia has been
able to score in recent days in the
donbas region
is not the end of the story
it is
a limited advance
it costs
uh enormous
efforts by the by the russian army
um and it has not
uh been a decisive
movement forward so i think that we are
at at this moment at a kind of stale
made in the donbas region
it's very difficult even for military
experts to predict
whether
in coming days or weeks
this will really harden into a kind of a
long-term war of attrition
remember world war one where uh armies
stood opposing each other for many
months at the enormous cost of lives and
and and
and and and
financial expenditure etc so
uh it's very difficult
to say how this will develop but i don't
think
that it would be
reasonable
to conclude that russia
you know is about
to win russia is not winning this war at
all russia may be consolidating its
current control over the donbass region
but that would be a very very limited
achievement that would be
not much more than what they got in 2014
right
right and
and on that point uh ambassador some
observers say that if the ukrainians
were to be given the hippie the heavy
weaponry that they're calling for that
the tide could turn in their favor
but we've got to point out that the big
powers and chief among them is germany
appear to be hesitant on that why is
that the case why are we seeing a
hesitant chancellor olaf schultz at a
time when the world is looking to
germany for that kind of leadership
well
i will grant you uh absolutely that
the german response to the demand
for
heavy
weapons by the ukrainian leadership has
been slow has been
hesitating but
the main
point here
is
let's not overestimate let's not
overrate the relative importance of
whatever german contributions
may be able to be provided or may not uh
come about the main bulk of the help
which ukraine has been receiving
not only since the start of the military
campaign but even earlier of course has
come from the united states
and from others so if germany is now
beginning
to be a little more forthcoming
regarding heavy weapons that may
contribute to the relative strength of
the ukrainian ability to defend their
territory or to make advances but it is
it is not a decisive factor so let's not
over
over
let's not blow this german question out
of proportion it's it's a relatively
minor issue in the in the in in the
overall
um in the overall equation of the
balance of forces
all right i i want to talk to this this
western resolve this this unity that we
saw
uh right at the beginning of this
invasion
the cracks are starting to appear uh
indeed in the european union you've got
different camps that have now emerged uh
you've got poland and the baltics and
i'll add the britons there although
they're not no longer in the european
union
and then you've got the big powers
you've got german you've got france uh
you have italy
calling for for for peace negotiations
calling for
an immediate end
to the fighting
what kind of peace is possible between
ukraine and russia right now
and and how can that peace be achieved
well look uh as as a as a as a former
peace
negotiator myself i know a little bit
about the conditions
to go from war to peace
in the current situation between ukraine
and russia
meaningful peace negotiations will only
be possible
once both parties and i insist on both
parties ukraine and russia
come to the conclusion that they can no
longer make meaningful advances on the
battlefield that they can not
win
this war right only if they both
accept the idea that this is about as
far as we can get and maybe it is now a
smart idea to write this down whatever
we have at this moment because it's not
going to get any better
are we at this moment now no we aren't
obviously russia believes that they can
still make
meaningful further advances in the
donbass region
obviously ukraine
is absolutely determined not to let that
happen but to try to push back the the
russian army
uh at least to where
the the line of contact was
in way back in in february before the
conflict started then maybe even even
further so we are not at the moment
where i would say meaningful peace
negotiations
can be conducted
is it is it a good idea
for major powers like france germany the
united states and others
to keep talking to president putin and
to demand that he withdraws his army
from ukraine and that peace negotiations
should be started of course it's a good
idea to do that but we know that the
moment has not yet come for that to
happen but but demanding and and
increasing the pressure
on the russians to um to stop the war
because it's a war which they conduct on
the territory of another state it's not
a war in russia it's a war conducted by
russia in ukraine and this is why russia
needs to stop and withdraw
okay so does it make sense then for
western allies
to give ukraine
offensive weapons given what you're
saying
well i certainly do i
i think that
it is
absolutely correct when president
zielenski says
this war will be decided
on the battlefield it is a matter of
weapons and of men of warfighting
capacity
whether at the end of the day
the diplomatic solution the diplomatic
outcome will be one that would involve
the loss of major parts of ukrainian
territory yes or no
so it matters
whether ukraine can
not only defend what they have but
regain what they lost and that and this
is why
um
uh the um
the the
procurement of uh of the necessary
weapons and ammunition and and
intelligence etc is of course of
paramount importance absolutely
let's talk about the negotiations you
ended off on the note about territory
over there ukraine taking back what it's
lost
but when it comes to negotiations
what needs to be on the table
we know that ukraine's offered
neutrality that it will not that will
essentially abandon its ambitions uh to
join the nato alliance
that's clearly not been enough uh for
the russians
does it ultimately mean then that
ukraine would have to be willing to seed
some territory
in negotiations aimed at achieving peace
well again i think that this depends
totally on what the territorial
situation will be at the moment when
meaningful
serious negotiations
will be
will be conducted
i hesitate
to take it for granted to taking it for
granted that ukraine shall forever
relinquish
its ambition to join nato
it's true that president zielinski
hinted that that mentioned
neutrality as a as a possibility but
that concession has not yet been made
and whether it is
smart or not so smart for ukraine to
offer
such a concession in advance
well let
let's wait and see what actual
negotiations will lead to look
ukraine will regardless of what outcome
what concrete territorial outcome
will be obtained ukraine will
will definitely need
internationally relevant credible
guarantees for its future territorial
integrity and whether that can be
achieved without ukraine being a member
of the nato alliance is
a good question
i am not so certain
that
any kind of guarantee short of nato
membership
would would offer ukraine the same kind
of security as eventual
membership in the north atlantic
alliance so my advice to
all the
the observers and certainly to my
ukrainian friends is
don't make
any
concessions
verbally or otherwise now
keep
your options open
and
let's go to the negotiating table with
all options on the table once the other
side is also willing to seriously
negotiate that's uh the idea and i think
that we will of course need
a negotiating framework that will not
limit
uh the participation to russia and
ukraine there will be some kind of
framework that would involve maybe the
permanent five of the u.n security
council maybe involve
the european union maybe involve other
neighboring states think of turkey think
of the you think of
poland etc so i think we will need some
kind of an international
contact group arrangement in order to
help
meaningful negotiations
being taken to a to a successful
conclusion with actual signal signatures
being affixed to it and and ratification
procedures being being introduced it's a
complicated process ending a war and
turning it into peace
uh ambassador as as we're going to the
close um
i just wondered
how could
ukraine's position be strengthened
in those negotiations and and how could
the west
help with that does it ultimately come
down to what happens on the battlefield
well the first point that i would make
is
um
it is
of course obvious even now after
about three months
of um
of war fighting
uh that
russia's
the ability of the russian army to
to conquer a large country like ukraine
is very limited
and that
russia
has
overstretched itself in terms of its
original war aim in other words it's
it's pretty clear
for me at least even now
that russia
will actually have lost
this war at the at the end of the day
whether they will be in control of some
part of ukrainian territory yes or no
that is in my view a minor question the
important
uh point to make is that russia
has not been able to and obviously quite
obviously is not going to be able to
dominate all of ukraine and to subjugate
ukraine to turn ukraine once again into
a kind of a vassal
of
of under russian control and russian
leadership that's the essential point
and that that means that uh russia
will
have to go into a painful process
of reevaluating its own capacity as a
great power
whether it is in the interest of the
russian
citizenry
to conduct expensive wars in syria uh in
places like like ukraine with tens of
thousands of uh young russian soldiers
uh dying for no
con discernible good reason at all
uh no one pro no one attacked russia no
one threatened to attack russia so i
think there will be a moment of
reckoning
for russia maybe not in the in the
immediate future while president putin
is conducting this campaign but i'm
absolutely certain that in the longer
run
in the medium and longer term there will
be
there will be these serious questions
being asked by the russian public in the
russian
among the russian political class and it
will be
a very difficult and painful process i
would imagine
ambassador ishinga just to bring us back
to what this ultimately is about this is
the invasion of a sovereign country an
invasion that actually began in 2014
if we're going to look at the facts
because russia is a nuclear power
does does that ultimately
mean
that ukraine
has to
make peace with the fact that it may
have to
do away with some of its territory is
that what this comes down to
well i would not i would not
automatically
conclude that because of the
uh
the fact that russia happens to be a
nuclear power
ukraine will will be forced to give up
uh territory
it is
one specific question which is which has
been hotly debated of course um
is it possible for ukraine for example
to reconquer crimea
well there are many voices out there in
the west and elsewhere which say well
the crimea question
is probably better left to future
negotiations between russia and ukraine
rather than
waging a war about that at this moment
uh given the fact that uh that russia
considers that now
since 2014
a part of russian territory and that
would mean that we would be looking at a
war not in ukraine but a war in russian
territory and
if you have a war on russian territory
russia could
claim
that existential issues are at stake for
russia because its territory is being
threatened and that therefore it is to
be expected that uh russia would would
be
uh would consider as
escalatory steps
uh using if you wish uh you know at the
end of the day nuclear weapons to defend
its own territory so the crimea question
in my view is a very complicated one and
i i would simply
not
come to the conclusion that any of these
issues should be
pre-decided by the outside world we
should leave it to the two parties
we should leave it to the the
battlefield as it as it evolves
and we should do whatever we can to make
sure that ukraine
can
reconquer the territories lost since the
24th of february as a minimum
and whether they can go further than
that
remains to be seen and then hopefully
we can we the international community
can be helpful in bringing about
a diplomatic
end a peace settlement that is equitable
and that will not produce
yet another uh
effort at war by either side
ambassador you've spent years as as a
diplomat uh you have
met
uh russia's president vladimir putin you
have seen
many wars over the years uh in your time
i wondered when you look at what's going
on in ukraine right now
indeed when that announcement came in
february that russia would be invading
ukraine what did you think what came to
mind
what lessons do you think
you've learned
looking at all of this
well what i have
learned what and what
um
what surprised me so
so much was that
there must have been a massive
misreading a massive misunderstanding
uh within the russian leadership
of what has happened in ukraine over the
last decade or so
it was true maybe 10 15 years ago that
ukraine
was just a little brother of russia and
and did not really have its own
fully developed national identity but
ever since 2014 everybody who has spent
time in ukraine and i have spent time in
ukraine um in in the in the months and
years since
everybody who's been there understands
that ukraine
has changed dramatically
ukraine
looks at russia now
no longer as the big brother but as the
enemy as
the power which threatens the very
existence of my country of ukraine
and i think uh the fact that that was
not
understood in moscow when the when the
decision was made to invade when when
apparently the assumption was that
russian tanks would roll into kiev and
would be welcomed by the population as a
liberating force
wow what a dramatic miscalculation that
was so
i think that one of my central
conclusion would be
uh governments are well advised
to make sure that they don't only listen
to their
own you know uh the gut feeling
uh
what i don't know how happers in putin
arrived at his conclusions but that
governments need
uh intelligence intelligent advice from
partners for parliaments
from advisory bodies and if russia had
made any use of such
of such elements of such help they would
certainly not have decided to attack
what a disastrous mistake that was
and for the west what are the lessons
learned and for the west of course uh
we must re-learn
the idea of deterrence
in a way you know deterrence by the west
of russia has failed
obviously the sanctions which we enacted
after 2014
did not
sufficiently deter russia from thinking
well
maybe we can not only do that again what
we did in 2014 maybe we can take it a
step or two further so
our deterrence effort failed and we must
rethink
how we can strengthen our own ability to
deter and to defend our interests our
borders whether this is the eu whether
it's nato
or whether it's
individual countries
the idea which was very popular in my
own country in germany for the last 30
years the idea that we are now going to
be enjoying forever the peace dividend
uh that idea is of course now
um
you know has gone out the window we uh
we need to accept the idea the fact
that war has returned
as an instrument of politics to the
european continent and that is why
defense
military capacity
and deterrence whether we like it or not
are back on the table as very important
elements of our of our own existence
my final question ambassador
what are your your thoughts about
vladimir putin
um
is
is anything that
peace negotiation would be aimed at
achieving
uh can can can people rely on that if
vladimir putin is still in charge at the
kremlin is is he the factor here
the problem of course as i see it is
that
there is no
uh is that that there is
one man rule in in moscow
uh in the in in
in the soviet days
uh they had a police bureau they had a
central committee uh
they governed by committee in if you
wish um
the putin system is is a system where
one man exactly
only one man makes the decisions and
that of course is particularly
dangerous for any country and especially
for a large and important global powers
such as such as as russia
i think that whatever
outcome
will be possible
to this war
it it will
it will need very very strong
international
guarantees
uh i think it would be foolish
to rely on verbal or written
declarations by
the russian federation
led by president putin after all the
deception
the misinformation
the disinformation
that we've
gone through in in recent months and
years
so i think
the trust
trusting russia
will actually
become possible only in a post-putin era
i would imagine
ambassador ishinga as always thanks
thank you very much for your time this
morning
thank you great talking to you i enjoyed
that very much thank you